no new dawn for turkey on a damp day in
Istanbul Reflections on five more years
for the country's authoritarian
president but it had gone to a second
round vote
we won we won says this man the
president is a fighter
but for those who wanted not only a
change of leader but a different
direction for the country there was
disappointment I don't believe
everything's going all right with my
country I would love some problems to be
solved I don't think my country and my
countrymen are treated as the way they
should be
by the government
celebrating with supporters in the
capital Ankara a triumphant ratchet type
erdogan pledged to address the country's
dire economic problems in the end he
overcame criticism over his response to
the country's recent devastating
earthquakes
but there was much more at stake in this
election than turkey's current political
issues during 20 years of his leadership
erdogan has led turkey on a more
religious and socially conservative path
his tenure has also seen the country's
Global significance grow what turkey
does matters to all of us it matters to
Europe it matches the United States
Madison Russia uh uh and so uh it's
um we must view the future with care
adamant is a tremendously cunning uh
Kenny transactional weed order of uh
he's a member of NATO but he's not
actually a reliable partner he sells
drones to Ukraine but he doesn't apply
sanctions against Russia
turkey's opposition had promised closer
ties with the west and greater democracy
the losing candidate described the
election as unfair but did not dispute
its outcome
the vote leaves erdogan's power and
policies cemented but turkey polarized
Lisa Holland Sky News